What a fun day. We are joined today by Kendra Adachi. You guys know her as the lazy genius. We love her. Kendra, hi. Hi, guys. It's so fun to be here with y'all. Thanks for joining us for a little, just a little chit chat. I'm a big fan of chit chatting. We love a little Friday chitty chat chat. We should say we're all remote. We're all like in some type of closet room situation. Totally. We're ladies who podcasts. This is how you do it. This is what. This is what? You do. In some ways, this is why you do it, because you can do your job in a closet, and it's great. Oh, before you hopped on, Kendra, I told Jenna, she was like, I didn't do my makeup. And I was like, oh, I slept in this shirt.
多开心的一天。今天和我们在一起的是肯德拉·阿达奇。大家知道她是“懒人天才”。我们很爱她。肯德拉，你好。嗨，大家好。很高兴能和你们大家在一起。谢谢你们加入我们的闲聊。我非常喜欢闲聊。我们很喜欢周五的闲聊。我们应该说我们都是远程连线的。我们都像是在某种壁橱房间里。完全是。我们是做播客的女士。这就是你的做法。这是什么。这是什么？你做的事。在某种程度上，这就是你这样做的原因，因为你可以在壁橱里完成工作，而且感觉很棒。哦，在你加入之前，肯德拉，我告诉珍娜，她说，我没有化底妆。然后我说，哦，我穿着这件衬衣睡的。
100%. Yeah, 100%. This is the shirt I slept in. I am wearing my pajama pants, but I changed my shirt. However, I told Angela, I slept in a gray t-shirt, and I took it off and put on actually a sort of slouchier gray t-shirt. So I changed out of my sleeping gray shirt into my daywear gray shirt, I guess. Substitute mine for the color black, and we are the same. Yeah, same.
百分之百。是的，百分之百。这就是我睡觉时穿的衬衣。我穿着我的睡裤，但我换了上衣。不过，我告诉安吉拉，我睡觉时穿着一件灰色T恤，我把它脱下来，换上了一件稍微宽松一点的灰色T恤。所以我从睡觉穿的灰色衬衣换成了我白天穿的灰色衬衣，我想是这样的。把我的颜色换成黑色，我们俩就一模一样了。是的，一样。
Well, we get our chit-chat suggestions from listeners. It's this really fun new thing we do, and people write in the best stuff. Our first one is coming from Missy S in Hearst, Texas. Let's hear what she has to say. Good morning, office ladies, longtime listener, first-time caller. My name is Missy and I am from Hearst, Texas. As I was listening to your second drink yesterday evening while I was making dinner, I realized that this is not right. What do I mean, you ask? Well, I've made a habit over the last five to six years, however long you have been podcasting to listen in the morning on my way to work. I'm a teacher. It's become habitual for me. It brightens my morning whenever there's a new show and I just love. you ladies. So this got me thinking, what are some things that you do in your life that you can only do at certain times of day? Whether it's going for a run, whether it's having fun conversations
嗯，我们的闲聊建议来自听众。这是我们做的一个非常有趣的新栏目，人们会写信来分享最棒的内容。我们的第一位听众来自德克萨斯州赫斯特的密西·S。让我们听听她要说些什么。办公室女士们早上好，我是老听众，第一次留言。我叫密西，来自德克萨斯州赫斯特。昨天傍晚我一边做饭一边听你们的第二杯酒，我意识到这不对劲。你可能会问，我指的是什么？嗯，在过去的五六年里，也就是你们做播客这么长时间以来，我养成了在早上下班途中收听的习惯。我是一名教师。这已经成了我的习惯。每当有新节目时，它都会让我的早晨变得美好，我非常喜欢你们这些女士。这让我开始思考，你们生活中有哪些事情是只能在特定时间做的？不管是去跑步，还是和孩子们进行有趣的对话
with your kids, whether it's whatever it is. I don't know. I just thought it was so funny that it felt so wrong to listen to you guys in the evening as I was cooking dinner because the habit has become to listen in the morning on my way to work. Thank you so much for all you guys do love you so much. Looking forward to many, many years of more office ladies. Bye. I love this question. It's deeply nuanced. I don't know that I've ever heard anybody ask a question like this before. It's very thoughtful. I love how in touch Missy is with her habits and routines and her attachment to them. I can relate to that. Okay, well, I think we should all tell Missy, what are our things that we have to do in a certain order? What's an example of one for you?
与你的孩子们，不管是什么内容。我不知道。我只是觉得很有趣，傍晚做饭时听你们的节目感觉太不对劲了，因为习惯是在早上下班路上听。非常感谢你们所做的一切，非常爱你们。期待还有很多很多年的办公室女士播客。再见。我喜欢这个问题。它非常有深度。我不知道以前有没有人问过类似的问题。这非常体贴。我喜欢密西对自己习惯、日常以及对它们的情感的了解。我对此很有共鸣。好吧，我觉得我们都应该告诉密西，我们有哪些必须按特定顺序去做的事情？对你来说，其中一个例子是什么？
you, Kendra? I recently tried to meal plan on a Friday instead of on Sunday afternoon. And it was what Missy said, where it was like, this is so uncomfortable. Like, my pants are too tight. Like, it just was like, this is, it didn't feel right. And so I just decided this is got to be this, this is a Sunday afternoon task. This is not a Friday task. It does not belong on a Friday. Nobody needs a meal plan on a Friday. But I also am so connected to my head. habits and routines. I'm sometimes too connected to them. And when I was thinking about this question, it made me think of things that I have done at different times on purpose just to like shake it up, you know? Yeah. So like working out at night instead of in the morning, like the first time I went to
你，肯德拉？我最近试图在周五而不是周日中午做膳食计划。就像密西说的那样，感觉太别扭了。就像，我的裤子太紧了。就像，这感觉不对。所以我决定这必须是，这必须是周日下午的任务。这不是周五的任务。它不属于周五。没有人需要在周五做膳食计划。但我也非常依恋我的习惯和日常。有时我甚至过于依恋它们。当我想起这个问题时，它让我想起了我在不同时间故意做的事情，只是为了改变一下，你知道吗？是的。就像晚上去健身而不是早上，就像我第一次去
the gym at 8.30 p.m. It was like, this is a whole other world. Look at all these people here. It's a whole different crowd. It was so bizarre. It was so bizarre. Or like baking at night. Like I think kitchen things, like after kids have gone to bed, that was sort of a different shift. So I think it's a really great question because it illuminates both sides. You know, like some things, it's just keep the things where they are. They're so happy where they are. And then other things, you go, actually, this is sort of a nice shake up. We're going to shake it up a little bit. What about you guys? I'm like you, Kendra. I sometimes, I do intentionally shake something up because I don't want to become an inflexible person. Sure. I like the safety of my routines. I like the safety of my order,
晚上8点半去健身房。感觉就像，这是完全不同的另一个世界。看这里有这么多人。完全是不同的人群。太离奇了。太离奇了。或者像晚上烤东西。就像我认为厨房里的事，比如孩子们上床睡觉之后，那是一种不同的转变。所以我认为这是一个非常棒的问题，因为它照亮了硬币的两面。你知道，有些事情，只要让它们保持原样就好。它们在原来的位置多开心啊。而另一些事情，你会觉得，其实，这是一种不错的改变。我们要稍微改变一下。你们呢？我和你一样，肯德拉。有时，我会故意做一些改变，因为我不想成为一个不懂变通的人。当然。我喜欢我的常规带来的安全感。我喜欢我的秩序带来的安全感，
but I don't want to become a person that's like completely thrown off by change. Lady, I must be so healthy for you. It is something I love about our friendship, Angela, because you are very flexible and spontaneous. You're like, I'll do stuff whenever I feel like it. When I have the window of opportunity, it's kind of true. But what's the thing you do, though, on a weekly basis, Jenna? Like, what's one of your rituals that you do at the same time? Laundry on Fridays.
但我不想成为一个完全被变化打乱阵脚的人。女士，这对你一定很健康。这是我喜欢我们友谊的一点，安吉拉，因为你非常随和和 spontan。你总是说：只要我想做，随时都可以。当我有了机会窗口时，我就去做。这倒挺真的。不过，珍娜，你每周固定做的一件事是什么？比如，你有哪些雷打不动在同一时间做的习惯？周五洗衣服。
I need to start the laundry process on Friday because I need it done by Monday. And if I start the laundry process, even Saturday morning, we're not going to make it. It's not, it's like it's not enough time. Because I want everything in the drawers folded, put away by Sunday night so that everybody wakes up Monday morning with all the laundry. It's all clean. We're not looking for socks in the dryer as we're on our way out the door for school. I mean, I get that.
我需要在周五开始洗衣服的流程，因为我需要它在周一前完成。如果我甚至在周六早上才开始洗衣服的流程，我们就来不及了。时间不够，因为那是不够的时间。因为我想在周日晚上之前把所有的衣服都叠好放进抽屉里，这样每个人周一早上醒来时都有干净的衣服。全都是干净的。我们不用在出门上学时还在烘干机里找袜子。我的意思是，我懂。
And if I start it too early, then stuff is dirty again by Monday. So, like, my laundry is, like, very sacred. Can I ask you a question about your laundry routine? How long do you think that you tried it out and found that boundary before you landed on? Oh, I need to start on Friday night so that everything is done on Sunday evening? I mean, my kids are a lot. 11 and 14, and I feel like I just figured this out last year. I'm really glad that's your answer because I think too many people, they create something from
如果我太早开始，到了周星期一东西又脏了。所以，我的洗衣服，就像是非常神圣的。我能问你一个关于你洗衣流程的问题吗？在你确定下来之前，你觉得你尝试了多久并摸索出了这个界限？哦，我需要在周五晚上开始，这样周日晚上就能全部洗完？我的意思是，我的孩子们很大了。11岁和14岁，我觉得我去年才刚搞清楚这一点。我很高兴这是你的回答，因为我觉得太多人，他们从
scratch, and they're like, this is going to work forever. And then they don't adjust it and find the thing. They don't find the limits that actually help them. And it sometimes takes actual years to learn it starts on Friday night and it ends on Sunday night. Like, that's when laundry happens. And so I actually kind of, I kind of love that it took 11 to 14 years to figure it out. But also the needs of your household changes. I mean, I have like adult humans now that I live with. I mean, they're still in high school, but they're like 17, you know, and they drive cars and craziness. And so I feel like some of our routines that we had when they were younger are totally different now because they drive themselves. Like my mornings are so different because
零开始，然后他们觉得：这会永远管用。然后他们不去做调整，去寻找最合适的方式。他们没有找到真正能帮到他们的极限。有时需要好几年的时间才知道它从周五晚上开始，到周日晚上结束。就像，那才是洗衣服的时候。所以我其实有点，我有点喜欢花了我11到14年的时间才搞清楚这件事。但同时，你家里的需求也在改变。我的意思是，我现在和成年人一起生活。我的意思是，他们还在上高中，但他们已经17岁了，你知道的，他们会开车，各种疯狂。所以我觉得我们以前在他们更小的时候的一些常规现在完全不同了，因为他们自己开车。比如我的早晨完全不同了，因为
I don't do school drop-off anymore. Like, that's going. They drive, tell me stories. I know. The future. I mean, Josh and I have a, like, a new morning together time that we haven't had. And I actually love it. We used to catch up at dinner time.
我不用再送他们去学校了。那已经过去了。他们自己开车，给我讲故事。我知道。未来。我是说，乔许和我现在有了一个全新的、我们以前没有的晨间共处时光。我其实很喜欢这样。我们以前是在吃晚饭的时候交流。
That's when we would come in and we'd start making dinner and that's when we would chat about the day. But now we kind of have this morning chat because we're not going, doing two different drop-offs and go on different direct. depending on, oh, we have a kid at middle school, we have a kid at high school, like, those are two different spots. Now the older kids drive everybody. It's amazing. So that's been really fun. But yeah, I'm not as structured as Jenna.
那是我们回家开始做晚饭的时候，也是我们聊天谈论这一天的时候。但现在我们有了这种早上的闲聊，因为我们不用去，不用去送两个不同的地方，不用走不同的方向。取决于，哦，我们有一个孩子在初中，我们有一个孩子在高中，那是两个不同的地方。现在大孩子开车送所有人。这太棒了。所以这真的很有趣。不过，是的，我没有珍娜那么有条理。
I don't have certain days I do things. I just do them when I see the need, which can make a structured person go a little berserk. My husband's very structured. So it's very funny to me because two of the people that are the biggest parts of my life, which is my best friend Jenna and my husband, are very similar in how they're. They're like, this is the day that I make tacos, and this is the day that I make, whatever it is. And I'm like, hey, guess what? Newsflash, we don't have to have tacos tonight.
我没有固定的哪一天做什么事。我只是在看到需要的时候才去做，这可能会让一个有条理的人抓狂。我丈夫非常有条理。所以这对我来说非常有趣，因为我生命中最核心的两个人，也就是我的好闺蜜珍娜和我的丈夫，他们在生活方式上非常相似。他们就像是：这是我做塔可饼的日子，这是我做其他什么东西的日子。而我说，嘿，猜猜怎么着？突发新闻，我们今晚不一定要吃塔可饼。
What? But I bought all the ingredients, you know? I'm like, let's go out. He's like, no. So that's kind of funny to me. But I do have one thing I consistently do, which is when I drive to tennis, which I play three times a week, I play Monday, Wednesday, Friday. I call my mom on the drive to tennis. And that's our time.
什么？但我把所有的食材都买好了，你知道吗？我说，我们出去吃吧。他说，不。所以这对我来说挺逗的。但我确实有一件一直坚持做的事，那就是当我开车去打网球时——我一周打三次，周一、周三、周五打——我在开往网球场的路上会给我妈打电话。那是我们的时间。
So every morning, around 8.30 in the morning, I'm calling my mom. And I forget sometimes, and I call her Tuesday, and that's her lady's Bible study. So then she puts me on speakerphone and I end up talking to everyone at ladies' bubble study. But every morning on my drive to wherever I'm going, I call my mom. And one time I just randomly called her in the afternoon. And she was like, what's happening? What's going on? And I'm like, oh, mom, I just thought I would call you in the afternoon today instead.
所以每天早上，大概8点半左右，我都会给我妈打电话。有时候我忘了，周二给她打，而那是她的女士圣经学习班时间。于是她把我开成免提，结果我跟女士圣经学习班的每个人都聊上了。但每天早上在我开车去任何地方的路上，我都给我妈打电话。有一次我只是随性地在下午给她打了电话。她就说，发生什么事了？怎么了？我说，哦，妈，我只是想今天改在下午给你打电话。
She was like, oh my gosh. But so she's very used to this routine as well that I call her on my drive in the morning. And I really treasure those chats. Oh, lady, I love that. Yeah. And she has the cutest thing she says, by the way. So on a Thursday, I call her as I drive in. Normally we podcast in person.
她就说，噢天哪。所以她也非常习惯我早上开车时给她打电话这个常规。我非常珍惜这些聊天。哦，女士，我太喜欢这个了。是的。而且她有一句超级可爱的话，顺便说一句。所以到了周四，我在开车时给她打电话。通常我们是面对面做播客的。
You know, we have a studio. And on Thursdays, I'll call her on the drive. And she'll be like, you're going to podcast like I am. Tell you and I said hi. And then on tennis days, every single time we speak on a tennis drive, she ends with, all right, Ange, go stick it in their ear. Everybody needs an Angela's mom. Oh, no.
你知道的，我们有一个工作室。在周四，我会在开车时给她打电话。她会说：你要去录播客吗？就像我一样。代我和他说声嗨。然后到了网球日，每次我们在开往网球场的路上通话结束时，她都会说：“好了，安吉拉，去把他们干掉吧。”每个人都需要一个安吉拉的妈妈。哦，不。
Angela, I'm thinking about how you said that both Josh and I are kind of similar. The two people you're closest to in your life are both these structured people. Well, you know, you and Lee are very similar. So clearly there's something about us where we're like, I need to attract this other thing into my life in two big ways. Through my best friend and my husband, I need a flexible, spontaneous laid-back person to balance my hyperstructure personality. And you did the same with me and Josh. You're like, I need two people who have a lot of order. I mean, absolutely.
安吉拉，我在想你刚才说乔许和我有点相似。你生命中最亲近的两个人都是这种很有条理的人。嗯，你知道的，你和李非常相似。所以很显然，我们之间有一种特质，让我们觉得：我需要在我的生活中通过两个重要途径把这种截然不同的特质吸引进来。通过我的闺蜜和我的丈夫，我需要一个灵活、随性、随遇而安的人来平衡我高度结构化的个性。你对我跟乔许也是这么做的。你就像是：我需要两个非常有秩序感的人。我的意思是，绝对的。
Kendra, what about you? Do you have that balance in your marriage? Oh my gosh. My husband's name is Kaz. I call us glitter and glue. He's the glitter. He's the glitter in every way. He is so fun. His birthday was this week. And we started this thing when we have like family birthday dinner where we do an acrostick of the person's name of like ways we love them or things about them. And it did morph into like just synonyms for him being old. But before I got to that, because my children are brutal. He turned into a roast. It did. It turned into a roast. My children are big roasters. But before that, like, when we did father, because my kids call him father. We're father, mother, brother, and sister. Like, it's chaotic, but it's great. It's very formal. So we started with father because like a joke was like, father.
肯德拉，你呢？你的婚姻里也有这种平衡吗？天哪。我丈夫叫卡兹。我管我们叫亮片和胶水。他是亮片。他各方面都是亮片。他太有趣了。这周是他的生日。我们开始了一个传统，当我们举办家庭生日晚餐时，我们会用这个人的名字做一个藏头诗，写下我们爱他的方式或关于他的事情。后来演变成了纯粹吐槽他变老了的同义词。但在我走到那一步之前，因为我的孩子们太残酷了。这变成了一场吐槽大会。确实如此。变成了一场吐槽大会。我的孩子们很会吐槽。但在那之前，当我们写“父亲”这个词时，因为我的孩子们叫他父亲。我们是父亲、母亲、哥哥和妹妹。这有点混乱，但很棒。非常正式。所以我们从“父亲”开始，因为有个笑话就像是：父亲。
And F was immediately fun. Everyone was like, oh, dad is fun. He's not funny. He thinks he's funny. He's a dad joke guy. But he is the one who is like, yeah, let's roll. Like, he's the spontaneous guy. He's the adventure guy.
然后“F”立刻就是“有趣”（fun）。每个人都说：哦，爸爸很有趣。他其实一点都不好笑。他以为自己很好笑。他是个讲爸爸冷笑话的人。但他确实是那个说：“好吧，我们走吧”的人，他是那个随性的人。他是那个冒险家。
He just makes everything sparkle. And I am like, and this is how we're going to get there. Here's my list to help. You know, like we really do balance each other that well. But yeah, he's not an organized guy. He's not an orally guy. He's a great help and a great partner. But we're good partners because we're so different.
他让一切都闪闪发光。而我则是那种：“这就是我们要怎么到达那里的步骤。”这是我的清单，来帮帮忙。你知道的，我们确实把彼此平衡得很好。但话说回来，他不是一个有条理的人。他不是一个按部就班的人。他是个绝佳的帮手，也是个伟大的伴侣。但我们之所以是好伴侣，是因为我们如此不同。
Yeah. I mean, I really related to everything you said. Glitter and glue is a nicer way to say. I'm usually like, I'm the hot mess and he's got his shit together. But okay, let's move on to our next chit-chat, Question coming from Kim W. in Fort Worth, Texas. All our questions are coming from Texas today. Thanks, Texas. To Texas gals. Let's hear what she has to say. Hello, office ladies. My name is Kim Westbrook, and I live in Fort Worth, Texas. And I was just wondering, who is a fictional character that you would hate to sit next to on a long flight? Can't wait to hear your guys' response. Have a good day. I mean, I knew mine immediately.
是的。我是说，我对你所说的一切都深有同感。“亮片和胶水”是比较好听的说法。我通常会说：我是个彻头彻尾的乱麻，而他把一切都理得井井有条。不过，好吧，让我们进入下一个闲聊环节，问题来自德克萨斯州沃斯堡的金·W。我们今天所有的提问都来自德克萨斯州。谢谢你，德克萨斯。致德克萨斯的姑娘们。让我们听听她要说些什么。你好，办公室女士们。我叫金·韦斯特布鲁克，住在德克萨斯州沃斯堡。我只是想知道，在长途飞行中，你最讨厌坐在哪个虚构角色旁边？迫不及待想听听你们的回答。祝你们有美好的一天。我的意思是，我一下子就知道了我的答案。
You did? Who is? Well, I don't know. Maybe it's because my kids loved Looney Tunes and we watched so many hours of Looney Tunes. But you guys, I would not want to sit next to Daffy Duck for any amount of time. He would just drive me crazy. And, oh, my God, he gets so annoyed so easily. I don't know. I don't want to sit next to Daffy Duck. That's a solid answer. Top that. Top Daffy Duck. So here's what I thought. I know there's a type of person that I don't enjoy sitting next to on an airplane. It is an arrogant man who doesn't know when to be quiet. Oh, yeah. So my first thought was Gilderoy Lockhart from Harry Potter, the one who just like wants everybody to, you know, he's like sign my books and he's always taking pictures and he's always talking about himself and he's lying about his experiences and he drives me and says. And then the other version of that, like a backup would be Gaston from Beauty and the Beast. Like that energy. A guest on. Yeah, that energy of like, hey, you're lucky to sit next to me. Yeah.
你知道？是谁？嗯，我不知道。也许是因为我的孩子们很喜欢《乐一通》，我们看了无数个小时的《乐一通》。但是各位，我绝对不想在任何时间内坐在达菲鸭旁边。他会把我逼疯的。而且，天哪，他太容易生气了。我不知道。我才不要坐在达菲鸭旁边。这是一个很扎实的答案。超越这个。超越达菲鸭。所以我是这么想的。我知道有一种人是我在飞机上最不喜欢挨着坐的。那就是一个狂妄自大、不知道什么时候该闭嘴的男人。哦，是的。所以我的第一反应是《哈利·波特》里的吉德罗·洛哈特，就是那种希望所有人都，你知道的，他会说“给我的书签名吧”，而且他总是拍照，总是喋喋不休地谈论自己，谎称自己的经历，这让我抓狂。然后是那种人的另一种版本，备选方案就是《美女与野兽》里的加斯顿。就是那种能量。加斯顿。是的，那种“嘿，你能坐在我旁边算你走运”的能量。
I'm like, Gaston would be really annoying. No. I'm not interested in this at all. This was the first thing that sprung to mind for me, which is I don't want to sit next to John Wick. What? Oh, because the assassins might come for you. That's a solid answer. might come. The whole plane is full of assassins now. Like, as soon as John Wick gets on the airplane
我觉得加斯顿会非常烦人。不。我对这个完全不感兴趣。这是我脑子里蹦出的第一个想法，那就是我绝对不想坐在约翰·威克旁边。什么？哦，因为杀手可能会来找你。这是一个扎实的答案。可能会来。整架飞机现在满是杀手。就像，约翰·威克一上飞机
and sits next to me, I'm like, well, I'm dead. Everyone's test. I mean, this is, I don't know what's happening to this plane. It's going down. Like, that is like a sure sign that this flight is not going to go well. There might be a rave before it goes down. You might have a quick moment of like a the club. Dish, dish, dish. But then it will be mayhem. Yeah. But that was my first thought. I was like, Because actually, the first thing I thought was, oh, it's kind of cool if John Wick sat next to me. That'd be neat. I'd get like, and I'm like, no, actually, that's bad news. Yeah.
坐在我旁边，我就会觉得：好吧，我死定了。所有人。我是说，这架飞机不知道要发生什么了。它要坠毁了。这绝对是这趟航班不会顺利的明确信号。在坠毁之前可能会有一场锐舞派对。你可能会有一小会儿那种夜总会的感觉。咚，咚，咚。但接下来就是混乱了。是的。但那是我的第一反应。我当时想：因为其实我最初的想法是，哦，如果约翰·威克坐在我旁边挺酷的。那会很整洁。我会得到，而我想：不，实际上，那是坏消息。是的。
If an action hero is getting on the plane with you, like, this is not the plane to be on. No. You want to get off that plane immediately. All right. So I'm picturing us in a row with Gaston, Daffy Duck. Oh, my gosh. That's the worst flight. I mean, Kendra, Jenna will tell you this.
如果有动作英雄跟你一起上飞机，这绝对不是一架好飞机的标志。不。你想立刻离开那架飞机。好吧。所以我在脑海里想象我们和加斯顿、达菲鸭坐在一排。哦，天哪。那是史上最糟糕的航班。我是说，肯德拉，珍娜会告诉你这件事。
I love to meet people. And so I have met so many people on the plane and talked their ear off. I mean, I'm not annoying. If they are also a talker, if they're not a talker, I mind my business. You know, I'd do my thing. But like one gal I met on the plane, we exchanged email information, and that was 10 years ago and we're still friends. I have lunch with her every once in a while. So I do like to chat.
我喜欢结识新朋友。所以我已经在飞机上认识了好多人，把他们的耳朵都聊出茧子了。我的意思是，我并不烦人。如果他们也很健谈的话。如果他们不健谈，我就会管好我自己的事。你知道的，我做我自己的事。但比如我在飞机上遇到的一位姑娘，我们交换了电子邮箱信息，那是10年以前的事了，我们现在还是朋友。我每隔一段时间还会和她一起吃午饭。所以我确实喜欢聊天。
If the other person wants to chat, I'm not a random chatter. You're not. I will confirm that Angela is like the best person to sit next to on a plane because if you need to talk to someone, she's going to be there for you. She's open and welcoming and she will chat with you. If you don't, she'll read her book. She'll do work on her computer. Or she'll journal. She might journal about you though. I might because I love to journal when I travel. I love to people watch and then write about them in my journal. They're my favorite messages. Do you have like an angle? Like I'm a little.
如果对方想聊天的话。我可不是那种逢人乱聊的人。你确实不是。我可以证实，安吉拉绝对是飞机上最适合坐在旁边的人，因为如果你需要找人说话，她会一直在那里。她很开放、很热情，会陪你聊天。如果你不需要，她就会读她的书。她会在电脑上工作。或者她会写日记。不过她可能会把你的事写进日记里。我可能会，因为我旅行时喜欢写日记。我喜欢观察人们，然后在日记里写下他们。那是我最喜欢的记录方式。你有什么特别的角度吗？比如我有点……
I'm always fascinated by people who write with pen and paper, like in a journal, on a plane or in a book, like when someone is next to them. And I think you have to really work the angle of the journal a lot so that the person next to you doesn't see your words. I feel like you're probably a pro at the journal angle. I'm a pro, and now I do it on my laptop, so I have to laptop angle. Listen, it's not just the person sitting next to you. It's the people behind you with the gap. They can see your screen. So I get my angle.
我总是对那些在飞机上或书里用纸笔写日记的人着迷，尤其当旁边有人坐着的时候。我觉得你必须非常巧妙地调整日记本的角度，这样旁边的人才看不到你写的字。我觉得你可能是一个调整日记角度的专家。我是个专家，现在我直接在笔记本电脑上写，所以我得调整笔记本电脑的角度。听着，不只是坐在你旁边的人。还有你身后座位缝隙里的人。他们能看到你的屏幕。所以我总是找好我的角度。
And then Jenna also knows I'm amazing at code names. So like, get ready for this, Kendra. Like a code name for you might be Lindra. No one's guessing that. Uh-huh. Jenna might be Pina. Yeah, I'm not the spy you want to hire. It's true.
而且珍娜也知道我很擅长起代号。所以，准备好听这个，肯德拉。比如给你起的代号可能是“林德拉”（Lindra）。没人能猜到那个。呃-huh。珍娜可能是“皮娜”（Pina）。是的，我不是你想雇的那种间谍。确实如此。
Ladies, this was a lot of fun. I enjoyed this. I hope that Missy enjoyed listening to this in the morning. That's right. On the ride to work. And before we go, though, we just want to ask you, Kendra, what are you watching right now and what are you reading right now? Because you have amazing taste in books, and I always like to hear what you're watching. Oh, that's fun.
女士们，这真的太有趣了。我很享受。我希望密西早上能听得开心。没错。在上班的路上。不过在我们离开之前，我们只想问你，肯德拉，你现在在看什么剧，在读什么书？因为你的书品超级棒，而且我也总是想知道你在看什么。哦，那太有趣了。
Well, I'll tell you what I'm rewatching. I watched for the first time a couple weeks ago, and I think I've watched it three times since. And I do not have a lot of time to just like dilly-daily and watch movies. But it's Wake Up Dead Man. It's the new Knives Out movie. I love that thing. Oh. I don't know this movie.
好吧，我来告诉你我在重温什么。几周前我第一次看，我想我从那以后已经看了三遍了。而且我其实没有太多时间去闲逛和看电影。但那就是《唤醒死者》（Wake Up Dead Man）。那是新的《利刃出鞘》电影。我太爱那个了。哦。我不了解这部电影。
I'm a big Knives Out person. The first Knives Out, I adored. It's like Top Five Movies for me. I love a rewatchable good time. That's my go-to movie. And so Wake Up Dead Man just came out. It's Josh Brolin and Jeremy Renner and Glenn Close and Carrie Washington. It's a really fantastic cast, and I loved it so much.
我是一个超级《利刃出鞘》迷。第一部《利刃出鞘》，我爱死它了。它对我来说是前五名的电影。我喜欢那种百看不厌的好片。那是我的首选电影。所以《唤醒死者》刚上映。里面有乔什·布洛林、杰瑞米·雷纳、格伦·克洛斯和卡丽·华盛顿。演员阵容真的太棒了，我非常喜欢。
Also, our family, we are a food competition show household. Oh, yeah. So currently we are watching 24 and 24 where you have to cook for 24 hours. We watch Top Chef. We watch Tournament of Champions. Like we are all in on food competition shows. It's like one of the only categories of things that all five of us really love. So that's a fun thing.
还有我们的家庭，我们是一个美食竞技秀家庭。哦，是的。所以目前我们在看《24小时大厨》（24 in 24），你必须连续做24小时的饭。我们看《顶级大厨》（Top Chef）。我们看《冠军锦标赛》（Tournament of Champions）。就像我们全家都沉迷于美食竞技秀。这是我们全家五口人都真正喜欢的少数几个节目类别之一。所以这很有趣。
I also from reading, I read a lot and I am reading this book called, I haven't finished you yet. So I don't know if the ending is going to, they're going to stick the landing. But so far it's great. It's called Mrs. Christie at the Mystery. Guild Library by Amanda Chapman. And it is a story about a woman who inherited basically like a library that also houses an exact replica of Agatha Christie's library. And they have mystery books in there and people come in and whatever. Well, one day this woman who's like, she's down on her luck and I'm not quite sure why. We haven't figured that out yet. But she walks into the library and
至于阅读方面，我读了很多书，我现在正在读一本叫作——我还没读完它。所以我不知道结局会不会烂尾。但到目前为止它很棒。书名叫《阿加莎·克里斯蒂与神秘公会图书馆》（Mrs. Christie at the Mystery Guild Library），作者是阿曼达·查普曼。这个故事讲的是一个女人，她基本上继承了一个图书馆，而这个图书馆里还藏着一个阿加莎·克里斯蒂图书馆的完美复制品。里面有悬疑小说，人们会进来阅读等等。好吧，有一天这个女人——她运气不太好，我不太确定原因。我们还没弄明白那部分。但她走进了图书馆
Agatha Christie is there. And she's like, is this really Agatha Christie or is this a crazy lady who wants to pretend she's Agatha Christie, and then someone gets murdered. And so then, like, she and pretend Agatha Christie are solving this case with this little, like, snappy redhead Irish kid that they sort of adopt to. It's like, it has been such a fun ride. It's the first book in a long time where I have been really excited just, like, keep picking it up. You know, like, oh, I want to stop what I'm doing because I want to go read some more of this book. Mrs. Christie at the Mystery Guild Library. So fun. Can I tell you my new favorite way to find out. book recommendations. Tell me. Because that's the thing. It's, you know, where do you get the
阿加莎·克里斯蒂就在那里。她心里想：这真的是阿加莎·克里斯蒂，还是一个假装自己是阿加莎·克里斯蒂的疯女人？然后有人被谋杀了。于是，就像，她和假装的阿加莎·克里斯蒂一起和一个他们顺便收养的、机智的红头发爱尔兰小男孩一起破案。就像，这真的是一次太有趣的旅程了。这是很久以来第一本让我感到非常兴奋、忍不住一直想拿起来读的书。你知道的，就像：哦，我想停下手头的事，因为我想继续读这本书。《阿加莎·克里斯蒂与神秘公会图书馆》。太有趣了。我能告诉你我发现书单推荐的最新最爱方法吗？告诉我。因为这就是关键。你知道的，你在哪里能找到
recommendation for the next thing to read? So I've started going to, and then I even hosted one. It's a book exchange party. So you invite a bunch of people over who love to read, and everybody brings a book, and then you go around, and you know, you have some charcutory or some little snacks or whatever. You chit-chat. Then everyone goes around, and they pitch their book. You get one to two minutes to pitch why you love this book. Then everybody draws a number and you do a white elephant exchange. And then everybody goes home with a new book. But then you also go home with the list of the books that everybody brought.
下一本要读的图书推荐？所以我开始去参加——甚至我还主办过一次。那是一个图书交换派对。你邀请一群喜欢读书的人来家里，每个人带一本书，然后大家围坐在一起，你知道的，吃点熟食拼盘或者一些小零食什么的。大家闲聊。然后每个人轮流发言，推介自己的书。你有1到2分钟的时间来推介你为什么喜欢这本书。接着每个人抽签，玩白象礼物交换。然后每个人都带着一本新书回家。但同时你也带走了一份大家带来的书的清单。
And it's amazing. It's my new favorite way to spend time with smart ladies. I have a group like that. We don't do the white elephant drawing numbers thing. We just sort of like politely circle the table with the books that everybody brought. And you're like, do you want to read this one first? Is it okay? have I read this one first. But it is, that is, I agree with you. That is one of the secret,
这太棒了。这是我与聪明的女士们共度时光的新最爱方式。我有一个这样的小团体。我们不玩白象抽签的那一套。我们只是礼貌地围着桌子转，看大家带来的书。然后你会问：你想先读这本吗？这本行吗？我应该先读这本吗？但这确实是，我同意你的看法。那是发现好书的秘密途径中，
like perfectly wonderful ways to find out books because then you also get to take them home with you. And I think a lot of us, like I love, I have a little free library outside my house. I love to share books. Like I buy a lot of books knowing that I'm going to spread them around and I don't need them back. Like certain ones I keep, I don't lend ones that I want to keep because I won't get the back. But I want to share them. And I think there are a lot of people that way. So you bring your book or two that's just your favorite meet like once a quarter. That's when my group meets once a quarter. And it's just the most fun. It's the most fun. I totally agree. I like it because I get to spend time with people who also love to read, which is really become a new passion of mine. I've always loved reading. But in the last probably year or two, I've become a voracious reader. And I love talking about books now with people. But I don't have the bandwidth for a book. book club. Yeah.
最美妙的方式之一，因为之后你还可以把它们带回家。而且我觉得我们很多人，就像我很喜欢，我家门外有一个小小免费图书馆。我很喜欢分享书。我买很多书就是为了把它们传播出去，并不需要它们被还回来。有些书我留着，那些我想留着的书我不借，因为我要不回来。但我想分享它们。我觉得有很多人也是这样。所以你带上一两本你最喜欢的书，大概一个季度聚一次。那就是我的小组聚会的时间，一个季度一次。这绝对是最有趣的事。太有趣了。我完全同意。我喜欢它，是因为我可以和也喜欢阅读的人共度时光，这真的成了我的新热情。我一直都很喜欢读书。但在过去的差不多一两年里，我成了一个如饥似渴的读者。现在我很喜欢和别人讨论书。但我没有精力去应付一个读书会。
Like, or the assignment of having to read a specific book in this month, because I want to read what I want to read. Same. So this other way of like sharing books with people, I love it because we're all just reading what we want. Yeah. My goal is to someday be invited to a book club. It hasn't happened yet.
比如，或者这个月必须读一本指定书籍的任务，因为我想读我想读的书。同感。所以这种和别人分享书的其他方式，我太喜欢了，因为我们大家都在读自己想读的书。我的目标是有一天能被邀请加入一个读书会。还没发生过呢。
You were invited to my book exchange party? That's true. This is true. But I want to be in a book club because there's always like really delicious, I feel like book club drama and my tennis ladies I play with. part of them are part of a book club, but then a few of us aren't. And there was a time where they would be talking about their books at tennis. I am not miffed that I have not been asked to be in this book club. It has not bumped me. I don't think about it. They talk about their books. I'm like,
你被邀请参加我的图书交换派对啦？那倒也是。这是真的。但我想要加入一个读书会，因为我总觉得里面会有非常美味的，我是说读书会八卦，而且我和一起打网球的网球女士们。其中一部分人参加了一个读书会，但我们有几个人没有。有那么一段时间，她们会在打网球时谈论她们的书。我并没有因为没有被邀请参加这个读书会而感到生气。这并没有困扰我。我根本没想过这事。她们谈论她们的书。我就觉得：
oh, that's fun for them. But this other gal, it really bumps her. And she does a lot of, like, when they talk about their book. I just want to be part of that. The drama. You're in it for the gossip. the stories. You're in it for the real life story. Yes. Not a book story. No, but I'll read the book. I'll read the book. But I'm also in it for the dynamics of the people that gather to discuss the book. Incredible. That's very on brand for you, Angela. You're there for the overall human experience. Yeah. Exactly. I do want to sort of, you know, have a call back and wrap us up here. I would dare to say that if I got on a plane and Agatha Christie was there, I'd get off. That's a solid choice.
哦，这对她们挺有意思的。但另一个姑娘，她真的很介意。而且她做了很多，比如当她们谈论她们的书时。我只想成为其中的一部分。那些八卦。你是为了八卦而去的。那些故事。你是为了真实生活的故事而去的。是的。而不是书里的故事。不，但书我也会读。书我会读的。但我也同样是为了那些聚在一起讨论书的人际动态而去的。太不可思议了。这非常符合你的风格，安吉拉。你就是为了整体的人类体验而去的。是的。完全正确。我其实想，你知道的，来个首尾呼应，在这里做个总结。我敢说，如果我上了飞机，而阿加莎·克里斯蒂也在上面，我会下飞机。这是一个扎实的抉择。
That's another person's going down. It's a very John Wick situation as well. I would like to see the plane with John Wick and Agatha Christie. How does that? You know, it's like two magnets. Do they repel or do they attract? Which crime gets solved and which one gets accomplished. It's pretty good.
那是另一个人要完蛋了。这简直也是个约翰·威克式的场景。我很想看看飞机上有约翰·威克和阿加莎·克里斯蒂会是什么样。那会怎样？你知道的，就像两个磁铁。它们是排斥还是吸引？哪个罪行会被破获，哪个罪行会被实施。这挺不错的。
Well, listen, everybody, thanks for joining us today on Friday Chit Chat. Thanks for writing in your suggestions. And Kendra, thank you so much for being a. part of this. We just love hanging out with you. Oh, this is so much fun. Thanks for inviting me. Everyone, check out Kendra's podcast, The Lazy Genius. We love it. We know you'll love it too. All right. See you next time. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah
好了，听着，各位，谢谢你们今天加入我们的周五闲聊。谢谢你们写信提出建议。还有肯德拉，非常感谢你参与其中。我们太喜欢和你一起玩了。哦，这太有趣了。谢谢你们邀请我。大家快去听听肯德拉的播客《懒人天才》（The Lazy Genius）吧。我们很爱它。我们知道你们也会爱上它的。好了。下次见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听办公室女士播客。《办公室女士》是天狼星XM奥迪赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。奥迪赛的执行制作人是莉亚·
Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was Mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《鲁珀特里》（Ruppertry）。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。